good evening everyone thanks for your
patience welcome to the fourth lecture
in our art and Technology lecture series
tonight I'm very pleased to welcome John
epaulet Oh John is an artist and a
curator at the Guggenheim Museum here in
New York and also a professor at the
university of maine in orono co-founder
and I believe co-director of the
Stillwater program for network art and
culture there this lecture series is
exploring issues at the intersection of
intellectual property technology and the
Arts it's an issue that John has
explored in his work in his writing his
artwork in his curatorial practice
please join me in welcoming John
ippoliti thanks for coming when I look
out at today's cultural landscape I see
two species of cultural producers one is
a prehistoric race of lumbering Giants
cold-blooded slow-moving leviathans
surfeited on monopolistic profits and
top-down economic models the other is a
relatively new species warm-blooded fast
scurrying underfoot of the giants these
new species are weaker but there's a lot
more of them and they're fast they're
light on their feet some of them are
even now taking flight to explore
ecological niches that the earthbound
Giants never could have some of them are
even nipping at the heels of those
jurassic giants but most of them are
just trying to stay out of the way not
get stepped on I trust my metaphor makes
it clear who of these two species I
think represents the future of cultural
production but media giants have little
interest in encouraging the unimpeded
evolution of new species Time Warner
Soros and Microsoft us Rex aren't
interested in evolution they want to
slow down a
halt these new species of small scale
producers who can flock when there's
reasons to be together but turn on a
dime when it's better to act
individually so I want to just give a
sense of which kind of creatures are in
my audience right now so I passed out
that little hangman exercise and hope
that you guys could tell me that anybody
figure out what the puzzle is or you
want to buy a vowel yes in the green
okay shoot for it ooh close what but
cheating who said cheating mark no David
cheating is the pedagogy of the Internet
wow that's pretty fast I guess I know
what species you belong to I see those
velociraptors sharpening their claws in
the audience cheating is the pedagogy of
the internet and I was hoping that my
little exercise would bring out the
enactment of what it was trying to
describe in words but they wouldn't
notice anything about the sheets of
paper might be a little different than
your average exercise you guys are just
smarter yeah different letters on okay
most times when I deal with the Jurassic
sub the cultural age of the 21st century
they're sitting there trying to figure
out what it is each individually but
when I deal with younger groups there
immediately talking to each other in
passing notes back and forth I got a
jeep would you get I got a day you know
and then they put it together very
quickly and I think this is a useful
sort of litmus test for exactly what
kind of expectations you have about
whether sharing is good or bad we call
sharing information cheating
quote-unquote when it happens among
people who aren't powerful even though
it's the very mechanism by which
stockbrokers museum curators you know
academics work in successful ways to
promote their own careers ironically
internet culture
in such an explosive way because it was
a system designed to supercharge the
practice that in other fields would be
called cheating and the results of this
hangman exercise give me a sense of sort
of the median age of the participants
because it's that age which has adapted
to and most quickly adopted the
technologies that come along with the
Internet age all really expressly
designed by the greatest technological
geniuses of our age for this purpose
this purpose of what by any other means
and by many people still today is called
cheating the web cell phones instant
messaging friendster email peer-to-peer
networks all of these are ways to
supercharge the circulation of ideas and
media and culture but what the reaction
from the system for the young peoples
and and some of you older but talented
cheaters in the audience what's their
reaction to this Incredibles almost
innate capacity for sharing well it's
not very good I'll give you a sense of
what I found in my little tour through
the web on cheating up scenarios of
academic dishonesty she's watching me
like a hawk this is the kind of paradigm
this is the body language of learning in
our culture not this but this keep your
eyes on your paper don't even look at
your paper you know that's that body
language right there someone looking
over your shoulder you making sure that
your eyes are on your paper and no one
else is looking at you this was actually
an exercise from a university trying to
get its students to encourage scenarios
to think about scenarios of academic
dishonesty and how to prevent them this
one keep your eyes on your own paper
this interesting hypothetical situation
ended with the teacher saying I was
impressed with your result because I
didn't think you were such a hard
working student student said yes I am
the teacher replied however you made
unfortunate mistake you know what it was
you also copied your classmates name I
told you to keep your eyes on your own
paper you even see sort of cartoons like
this class who can tell me what I
preserve in this jar
the last student got cheating on one of
my tests this is the reaction the
academic establishment has toured
cheating and it finds its more expensive
if not any more sophisticated ethically
manifestation in things like turn it in
academic software that checks plagiarism
that is of highly questionable ethics
and costs universities tens of thousands
of dollars that they could be spending
on other academic programs I think the
most egregious example i have seen
brought to my attention by how abelson
of MIT is the university of texas at
austin i like making fun of texas this
is a great excuse to do so this was a
memo sent around by the general counsel
it's a chief law dude at the University
of Texas advising their professors what
to do about student cheating now listen
to the kind of cheating what's going on
my lecture written in verbal
instructions the beginning class could
look something like this so this is a
license I would hand out to you at the
beginning of a course along with the
description of where we meet and what
the grading policy is my lectures are
protected by state common law and
federal copyright law they are my own
marginal expression and I record them at
the same time they delivered them in
order secure protection I'm recording
this remember that whereas you are
authorized to take notes in class
thereby creating a derivative work the
authorization extends only to making one
set of notes for your own personal use
and no other use you are not authorized
to record my lectures provide your notes
to anyone else or make any commercial
use them without express prior
permission from me so when you come out
of class today and someone says hey what
did John talk about a lecture not at
liberty to discuss it this is the
attitude that major universities this is
not podunk University this is that other
university in Texas this is the attitude
that major universities are taking
toward learning in our culture today and
it's all a kind of reaction to this
concern about cheating well you can see
the same kind of parallel in the digital
arts the previous speakers in the series
joy Jeffrey and Siva talked about the
relevance and value that remix culture
the ability to take source material and
recombine it neways has for photography
painting and music well if it had that
effect for those older forms culture
that's born digital
gets absolutely super charged by the
internet and the amazing new layers of
access made possible by digital
revolution let me give you one example
I'm only doing this because the guys in
the room are made it so I have to kind
of show it to you let's see here is the
net art diagram created by MTA a artist
collective internet art is a profoundly
prolific and very fast-paced of medium
and genre that really exploded on the
scene in the mid-90s and has continued
more or less unabated since then this is
a sort of seminal image or a emblematic
image from that period suggesting that
internet art doesn't happen on the
screen it happens in the network itself
well the artists of mtaa decided to open
source if you will their diagram which
was itself a kind of artwork by allowing
the vector file a illustrator file to be
reused by other people I'll show you one
example of how it was reused they still
don't know neither do I the person who
created this this is the complex net
diagram to go with the simple net
diagram as you can see it starts the
same way but things get rather Byzantine
after a while down through all kinds i
have the architects in the class enjoy
this which is also engineering and we'll
get to biology there's the biology ok
you can refer this system ok it's quite
rokoko at certain point and then no
military industrial network diagram back
to the computer again ok an example of
remix culture at its most baroque
there's lots of other examples on just a
few very quickly shredder is a famous
work by internet artist Mark Napier that
allows you to remix someone else's
website let's take I don't know that
could be anything sony com
we will remix sony's website what what
shredder does to sony's website is
really turn it inside out what was small
becomes large what was hidden becomes
visible the tiny snippets of JavaScript
that we're in the background you didn't
even see suddenly become emblazoned in
these giant blue letters marching across
the screen the large banner that was the
splash page image becomes a tiny
thumbnail sort of late a layered into
the background and you can do this with
any page on simply by through the magic
of D HTML and the fact that in the
internet as it was originally designed
you have access to everything or you
know just about everything within reason
that's what I mean cheating is the
pedagogy of the internet when the
internet started as we know it was
because people wanted a way to sort of
send off ideas academic data scientific
information artworks and media back and
forth through this ether that no one had
control over and everyone had access to
within the realm of people who had
access to the Internet at that time and
the protocols that drive most of the web
for example still operate on that
principle right HTML is fully open code
you can spider into any piece of it be
it's cascading style sheets or
JavaScript except for the you know in
its original manifestation all of these
things were available and so someone
like Mark Napier could literally turn a
web page inside out using that access
one more example of a work that I was
involved in that I'll give you is the
unreliable archivist this is something
that worked with a I can find it yeah
this was based on a a website pretty
much the first and foremost site for
Internet are curated called a de web
everybody knew about it everyone waited
to see who is the next artist who's
going to be on it and two colleagues and
I John Apple Janet Cowan and keith frank
totally remix the site we took the
aspects of the every page from the style
the layout the image the text and
categorize them and how do we categorize
them well if you open the slider you can
see that
they're all in this particular version
set on plane and that's because this is
the plainest style the plainest image
the plainest background color and so
forth that we found on a de web but you
didn't have to stop there you could go
to a enigmatic text or an enigmatic
image or an enigmatic style that is the
colors and so forth an enigmatic layout
again all these things come separately
in in the HTML and so they can be
modified separately you can go to a
loaded and as in sort of sensational
style layout so forth and if you want to
get really crazy you could combine the
most preposterous language most
preposterous images style and layout and
look at it all there and if you had any
doubt as to the fact that you know this
ridiculous kind of combination of things
actually wasn't out of web you could
view the sources where they came from
and say oh come on no one would put that
crazy flower background in an actual
page well you could just look at it and
this should open it for us in its
original context okay so that was the
original site you could do that for the
whole thing so that's another example of
messing with someone else's stuff
without their permission give you one
more example more recently using the
Nutella file sharing program a guy named
jason freedman created a project called
na jie network oral ization for nutella
and if i can get the sound going here
and what do i have to do to turn on the
sound ok if it was on i think it would
be making little BP sounds did you hear
BP sounds let's see well while that's
working i'm going to do a search for I
don't know something public domain
Beethoven wouldn't want Columbia
University to try it now there we go ok
when one Columbia University violate any
any copyrights over the Nutella
peer-to-peer network this kind of
wrapper for Nutella is searching for
Beethoven tracks and now it is playing
them in a rather random series of
selections determined by the software
and buy some some choices I've made by
how I want to mix it
in this case I've chosen to vary the
playback speed a lot very the playback
volume not at all move among downloading
songs slowly quickly so on and we get
the idea it it becomes this kind of
interesting Cajun collage it also
becomes a kind of interesting
sociological document you notice that
Beethoven wrote Ave Maria I don't
remember that happening so it also
represents the way that users refer to
these tags and kind of spiders across
the network in a way that wasn't
necessarily intended by the people who
created Nutella or put all these
supposedly Beethoven mp3s out there
online ok let's let's roll over
Beethoven here for a minute cancel oh
okay bye-bye ya heard you ok so just
several examples from the world of you
know remix culture and it might seem
that because this world is so rich and
so you know sort of a fluorescent that
it would be clear that you know there's
a value in in keeping artistic remix
alive but alas no artists have been no
more able to influence intellectual
property law and legislation than
students in fact what you're looking at
here is a an organization an event
sponsored by among others Columbia
University on 2002 called art technology
an intellectual property it was a
meeting an upstate New York this big
mansion took a week had 60 people there
were xne a chieftains there were
representatives of the movie industries
and the recording labels there were
copyright registrar's from the US
Copyright Office lots and lots and lots
of people with law degrees all the
people that I met their of the people
that I saw there was one artist if you
count me and one technologist
art technology and intellectual property
you do the math there was no chance that
we were going to influence the white
paper these people wrote this big book
that went up to Congress to advise them
what to do about intellectual property
and what was the excuse oh the RIAA is
taking care of us they're representing
all the musicians the mpaa they take
care of filmmakers you know the
aggregator the content aggregators the
culture industries those are the people
who are representing the artists so you
didn't really need to have artists
they're wrong artists and students and
other people who represent these new
species of fleet-footed weaker but more
mobile cultural producers need to have a
say need to be able to influence the
system we haven't succeeded yet so we've
got to figure out some other way besides
the you know the the sort of system as
it is to acknowledge or break a system
that refuses to acknowledge that things
have evolved past the pedagogical and
economic models of the past so what is
that how are we going to do that I refer
to it in the title as how to hack
copyright for fun and profit but let me
be a little clearer about that by fun I
don't mean schadenfreude I don't mean
writing computer viruses or spewing spam
or tying up random servers with denial
of service attacks you know that's for
script kiddies and where's dudes I mean
serious fun I mean the kinds of art that
you've seen that Miss uses technology to
uncover new possibilities reveal
underlying ideologies for profit I don't
mean cash from exchange economies I'm
not saying we should all go sell hot
copies of Photoshop and cds and photo on
Canal Street I mean there are legitimate
business plans that work within an open
model that work with the technology
against it even if they're not business
as usual these models of business as
unusual are very interesting and in some
cases quite profitable there's also the
rewards of gift and reputation economies
that I think our way undervalued in our
current culture finally that term I use
hacking copyright I don't necessarily
mean hacking individual copyrighted
material although I think there are
occasions where that's ethical I mean
hacking the system of copyright
proposing alternatives to the existing a
copyright to create innovation that
benefit creators in
the benefiting middlemen some of these
information innovations are going to be
familiar to you some of the previous
speakers have mentioned Creative Commons
licenses they never went into detail
about them I'll try to do that if I have
time but I'm also going to show you some
of these innovations that are relatively
new on the horizon I'm especially
interested in those innovations that
privilege creation instead of
consumption because again I think that's
something that is represents the
perspective of this new species do it
yourself rather than watch it yourself
this is also a theme that eben moblin
who all you know I hope here at Columbia
Law School refers to in his dot
communist manifesto and that's something
I'll be rushing back on in a bit first
though let's take a look at some of
these new innovations hacks of the
system Creative Commons the best-known
inspired by the GNU GPL of the Free
Software Foundation that opens source /
free software license that is basically
stimulated a vast new area of software
development new paradigm as well you've
probably seen but maybe you haven't
might as well bring it up the Creative
Commons get creative movie how many
people have seen that the flash
animation that's probably worth showing
first few minutes of it then I'll need
some sound for this as well this was a
flash animation they created to try to
get people to understand the concept
behind their licenses that's not going
to help
these are Jack and also no white stripes
they're a band from Detroit they make
black and roll without a bass guitarist
this is C MacDonald of the veteran band
Red Cross Steve thought might try to use
a bass player so he fronted himself he
took the whites with a loop of white
blood cells and we recorded it laying a
base crack down on every song then he
released the results as np300 proximate
even made up a new album cover entitle
rip began putting
online without permission from the white
stripes or their record label during the
project he bumped into Jack White who
gave him spoken assent to continue and
that is when you skip the intermediaries
in collaboration across space and time
creative co-authorship the people you've
never met standing on the shoulders of
your peers it's what the internet is all
about it can be not easy when you skip
it couldn't it be easier still not many
of us are liable just to Barney the jack
white light and he's not gonna let just
anyone by the base over your songs in
anything but what about other artists
who might want you or me to play be able
to
they don't mind enter one of the
Internet's most famous citizens face for
me to the world over public identity
rivaled only by a handful of corporate
giants and global superstars the big
copyright see everyone little bit big c
stands for big singing all rights
reserved bixi means asked permission Big
C protects copyright owners and notifies
the rest of us of their ownership the
time was when you have to make see
anything in rotary cutter right or else
it entered the public domain the commons
of information when nothing is owned and
all is permitted you had to put the
world on notice to Warner that'll fix
his job and was a useful one what
changed the law but late 1980s US war
had changed so it works become populated
automatically the moment they made the
moment you hit save on that research
paper a second mission it's matt
approach instant you let your pin from
that cocktail napkin doodle your
creation is copyrighted where the Big C
makes a cameo or not so suddenly there's
no quick way of knowing whether
something's on or not the new rules may
be clear about how you get to own work
you don't have to do anything but they
say nothing at all about
you want to allow certain uses of your
work so what well if you're a digital
filmmaker who every frame must be
cleared by an army of lawyers before
making a cut what if you're an
evangelist label won't that you put a
song on a file-sharing Network or if
you're a professor trying to put your
online course materials order your indie
da chasing down permission to use every
snippet of song in your sonic collage if
you're one of these people then you go
so what we interrupt this brainstorm
call the lawyers you drop what you're
doing and call all over you ask for
permission you can do the work of it
doesn't mind if you use it because you
have no idea what the author's intent is
you ask for permission you can share
some of your legs or you venture forward
unsure what your risks and rights are
exactly or in a haze of legal value you
can know that bottom line big scenes out
of a job little men are not enter
creative commons creative commons want
to find an easy way to help people tell
the world up front that they want to
allow some uses of their work we call
the experts the US Copyright Office for
advice better response there's no real
answer get creative so we got created
how our CC brand marks works for the
government commons licenses instead of
standardized copyright licenses
we encourage on our website we wrote
these licenses so that lawyers and
courts breather then we translated the
language you can read and then we can
get into new language now CC is meant to
compete it allows you to retain your
copyright on a brand in the world
permission to make certain uses of it
upon certain conditions if the Big C is
like a red light then CC because he said
no trespassing the CC says please come
in it makes you said all rights reserved
CC says some rights reserved so you can
use the powers of the net five works
read share and build upon and to invite
other people to transform or trade yours
that you can get created not only what
you make how you make available so you
can collaborate across space so you can
be a co-author with some narrow bed so
you can stand on the shoulders
your peers follow without asking
permission because permission is already
been branded created problems get
creative
okay that's that's the animation from
Creative Commons that gives you a quick
version now the idea again is to do for
digital content movies media music and
so forth what the GPL did for software
and it's been incredibly successful in
my book 5 million licenses exists out
there online already on web pages that
you can track that's about one in every
1,200 pages and if you think about how
big the web is that's an amazing
penetration given that they started in
2002 they've had major media outlets
Wired magazine the November issue
included a CD with Creative Commons
licensed works from the Beastie Boys
David Burns and host of other folks you
can sample some of them for commercial
remixes some of them for non-commercial
purposes they have also worked with
other organizations like soundclick
integrating the license into their
upload system 75,000 songs licensed with
Creative Commons licenses in only three
months they've got a pretty nifty device
a kind of beta software that you can
download called publisher I've got a
copy of it right here on my desktop
welcome to publisher this tool will help
you put your audio and video on the web
with a Creative Commons license so let's
suppose that you have you don't want to
do a website you want to actually embed
it in an mp3 why would you want to embed
a Creative Commons license and an mp3
rather than just notify people about
that license on your website really good
reason what do people do with mp3s yeah
they share them they put them on an ipod
they send them through kazar to tell or
whatever so if you get an mp3 downloaded
its away from its source it doesn't
necessarily have a tether back to the
place that the license originally was so
they created this tool to help you do
that so basically you create this kind
of box you dragged in let's say I've got
my amazing song mp3 here I'm going to
drag it into the publisher and what it
will do is sort of assimilate that mp3
file and then it prompt me to ask what
kind of license I want to apply to it
and instead of having that license go up
on a website or whatever it will
actually embed it into the id3 tag of
the mp3 so when that reference it was
made in
the animation to making something
computers can reap a little door with
little numbers that's XML it's an XML
flavor called RDF that specifies exactly
what the license terms are of your
particular file in this case I'm going
to choose let's see I'll say my you know
who I am so people can find me if I can
spell my name right let's say I did this
in 2002 and let's say it's a an audio
file i can add advanced information if i
want about you know other things i can
say no I don't want commercial uses I'm
going to allow people to modify it and I
want a generic there's also different
nationalities with generic one I can say
next you can give me a password to the
internet archive which is a publicly
accessible place to post stuff people
don't often realize this but they allow
people to post open source culture there
and then if I hit next it will actually
upload it it needs to know what kind it
is and now it's uploading it to the
internet archive and will return a URL
so that even if I don't have a website
i'm just some kid who made a song with
garageband suddenly I've got a Creative
Commons license piece up on the web with
a URL to share with my friends so that's
a pretty amazing little piece of
software I think they've done they've
been busy with other aspects of XML
including a search engine this is the
first XML search engine I've ever used
and it spiders for things I've looked at
sunset before just because that's so
obvious these people want in the back of
I don't know a student project or a
commercial project whatever fine works I
can even use for commercial purposes and
looks look at images and search now this
is looking across the web at all
different images of sunset basically
that have certain licenses and some of
these have attributions some of them
have no derivatives this one only has
attribution all I got to do is give this
person's name and I can use their sunset
let's see if it loads boom I found a
sunset for use in my project and I know
that it's got creative commons license
because i found it using their xml
search engine what else have they been
up to well they've been working out a
deal with morpheus the
peer-to-peer software where the this
particular file sharing system would
actually tagged files that download as
creative commons enabled let's see if I
can find a good example you can even
test to make sure that the license is
correct because someone could of course
take a Madonna mp3 and put their own you
know Creative Commons license under what
fake it but creative license Commons
wouldn't have registered that as a
Madonna CD and so you can check back to
make sure there's a referring URL for it
so you know they're being creative both
in the technological and the cultural
side and I think there's a lot more that
they have to do but they've made a big
lot of progress to date however I have
to say that Creative Commons is focused
primarily on consumption rather than
creation so if you're a creator if
you're someone who really wants to find
collaborators who wants to use new tools
who wants to take advantage of this
remix culture from a Creative Commons of
perspective most of most of the way that
you know for example there's quite a few
of these tracks on this particular CD
there by well-known artist Chuck D and
so forth but many of them simply allow
people to share them they don't
necessarily allow re mixing especially
for commercial purposes well that's
understandable their big name artists
they wanted to get the sort of peer
pressure a big name artists but some of
us have been working on environments
that really shift the emphasis from
consumption to creation in particular
I'm thinking about my fellow colleague
in Maine at stillwater the the placemark
described Jolene bleh and I along with
students John Bell matt james Jerome
nope and Justin Russell we've been
working on this thing called the pool
here's an example of the pool it's
really supposed to be an open
architecture for collaborating on text
art code pretty much anything this is a
sort of emergent diagram of the most
prominent themes of the pool right now
it's got a lot of stuff in it about 400
projects so we asked people to to sort
of jump into it by picking a theme first
I'll pick gun and let's pick sharing and
this will bring me by default into the
art pool
but it will select only those artworks
that have sharing as their kind of one
of their themes and what you're looking
at is a representation of all of those
ideas that were thrown into the pool and
I can find out more about them by
rolling over them the larger and image
is the more sort of work has been done
on it and I mean that in a very specific
sense because if I take a look more
closely at one of these projects I can
see from the left knowing the pool that
there is a version history of this
project it has been through three sort
of levels of production the first and
intent is simply an idea thrown into the
pool I want to make a website about you
know the last election and you know what
happened I want to make a peer-to-peer
software system that works only on
rendezvous or I want to you know write a
text about on the comparing John Cage
and richard stallman you know whatever
it is those ideas can be thrown very
quickly into the pool and very quickly
get feedback now the feedback manifests
itself in this kind of mapping there's a
reason for this diagram that you can
barely see in this light the two axes
upon which these guys are rated R
approval higher up to the top that is
something that's been rated higher by
the community floats to the top that
kind of metaphor a lot of aqueous
metaphors in the pool and recognition
goes to the right that is the more
review something has had the more to the
right it appears which basically means
if something's in the upper right hand
corner it got very high reviews and a
lot of them chances are it's going to be
an interesting project something in the
lower right-hand corner got a lot of
reviews and they were all shitty so it's
a way to take a lot of material and
encourage a lot of brainstorming a lot
of feedback back and forth but also make
some sense of it and what I can do is to
I can see what be good sense well as
lots of fun stuff you can do with the
pool but if I just want to show you for
example the details about this
particular project again it works in
series of stages the first stage is an
intent and it's simply a description
just a verbal description that can be
reviewed this got two reviews & 8 & a 3
and you can look at the details of the
review they only get conceptual ratings
at this stage but then someone can make
what we call an approach and approach
being a kind of mock up for it how would
this thing actually work not making it
yet but saying how it would work I do it
in flash or here's a Photoshop image of
what the splash page might look like or
here's a technical diagram of how the
network might work and you can review
the approach this one got quite a few
reviews you can also because it's past
the level of a pure description start to
give it license properties so in this
case you see it had attribution and
non-commercial at this particular stage
but then you can sort of follow the
version stream or kind of history the
approach did change once and finally it
in even engendered a release and the
release got you know its own reviews and
you can look through those and so on you
can compare projects so see you know
kind of the difference between different
projects in the pool again I've opened
up deliberately only the only the ones
that have to do is sharing when I open
up all three hundred they really occupy
the screen quite a bit but we have a lot
of filters to help us look through those
and ways to to to quickly find and
navigate through the material that that
the pool represents and it's been a
pretty interesting project for those of
us who have been working on it because
we use it in our classes all the time
and it really is an encouragement of
people to share and information
collaborate with each other fine
collaborators evaluate each other rather
than this kind of I'm head tucked over
my own paper kind of approach we also
though recognize that it's useful for
people students to find each other and
creators to find each other in the pool
so we built this this this kind of
network graph or it's a social network
system that trolls through project's see
who's collaborated with whom and I just
picked someone Justin Russell here it's
one of the collaborators one of the many
in the pool I can graph him at various
levels so if i want to see his projects
then i can just graph those okay now
there's Justin and he's contributed a
lot of projects to the pool at this
stage the dotted pneus of the line is
how we've been much effort he's put on
them how involved he's been so forth but
if I go further by spidering past the
projects to who was involved in those
projects who might get a more
complicated diagram we're still working
out the layout on the page but basically
there's some that he's worked on by
himself but there are others that he's
worked on with other people and if I go
like all the way in spider all the
relationships between these people the
diagram can get very complicated let's
say Matt changed I can spell right I
doesn't like doing okay let's pick him
here's someone who's done a lot of work
in the pool and still graphing him I
guess yeah Wow okay so this is the kind
of connection that you can make in
working in this kind of open environment
the pool is a system unto itself unlike
creative comments was much more
distributed where you can license your
own work on your on your own website the
pool requires you to in some way it
although it doesn't contain projects
it's sort of a way to register projects
but this is the benefit that you can
basically see the relationships you have
between other people and build them
incredibly kind of connective way I
mentioned reputation was an incentive
for open collaboration and this Grapher
is one way to kind of get that
reputation or at least represent it one
more thing I'll mention is the open art
network this is a and a system I've been
working on for a while it includes quite
a few artists in this city as well as
around the world people who have decided
that it's a good idea to in a creative
common style way represent allow other
people to reuse your work but in this
case it's particularly about the source
now we know that in the world of
software the source is a really valuable
thing right that's what makes New Lenox
powerful is you have access to the
source lots of people can work on and
improve it whereas Microsoft Windows its
proprietor it's closed you can't walk
the building and ever sort of share the
information with anyone else kind of
like that UT Austin license for students
well there's a lot of rich media that
internet artists and digital producers
use that isn't necessarily just code not
just Perl scripts or Java on and what we
were interested in doing was exploring
all those different options so here we
do have things like okay this is John
Klimas the gameplay which is C code for
a gameboy console we've got a director
of project macromedia director by Mark
Daggett Alex Galloway is a perl script
mark napier has java programs but we've
also been looking at this idea of
actually making an official license out
of it we actually proposed this to the
Creative Commons and we're talking right
now about adding this into the mix as a
kind of source license we have other
fancy names for it that's kind of the
basic idea and one thing that I think
I'll show you in a couple examples of
how easy it is to modify the sources
like this let's take a look for example
at just you know one of many digital
digital art kind of you know systems
right now the application you could buy
this is fruity loops it's something that
students especially like to use to
modify culture and me grab a here's a
here's a version of a sign this was made
in like 30 seconds by one of my students
using fruity loops sort of sounds like
Mortal Kombat I think I'll see if it's
plays hello is it plain it's not okay
there we go
ok
that's it but now I ask them to do this
sort of screen grab in which they showed
how easy it was to modify something so
now the students going to pick a
different instrument change one of the
tracks drag the line across and I gave
them the the assignment was in three
clicks that counts as a clique because
you can hold it down until counted as a
click in three clicks or three steps you
had to modify something significantly in
a way that demonstrated a difference
between that and the original file so
here's the different version this would
have been incredibly difficult to do
with something like sound edit if you
were just given the waveform right wave
files mp3 files those are great I'm glad
people are applying Creative Commons
licenses to them but they're not as
powerful as having the original the
source okay the fruity loops file the
garageband file the you know many acid
all these different applications that
can modify music and you see within
three steps you're able to do things
like change the Tambor instrumentation
without changing the pitch very
difficult to do if you're just like
editing the mp3 itself there's
comparable you know modifications it can
be done to visual files just as an
example those of you who work with these
technologies you know this you know like
the back of your of your hand because
you use it all the time okay here's a
here's just an illustrator file that a
student is going to modify quickly
changing the color changing the the the
outlines bulking out the shape with a
pucker tool you know just by dragging it
around so that in the end with a few
clicks it bears almost no resemblance to
the original something that would be
actually rather difficult to do with
just Photoshop and a JPEG if you've got
access to the original illustrator file
this kind of digital manipulation is
really trivial and as you can see it
generates quite a very different result
from the original okay so the goal was
to create this kind of a new form of
license based on sharing the media
source and as our proof of concept we
sent this to Creative Commons they got
kind of a kick out of it this is their
original movie that you saw a few
minutes ago I won't play the whole thing
but
that's get creative and one of my
students created this in response
really come starting as a new way to
share work into the air people all
around the world using CC files movie
files control the sexy he won't shake
reducing their stories movie fun or
flash message well I happened with the
source files raw data used to create
someone what you're only he took off the
goatee once he know customized parts the
license key or here DJ a little higher
quality the water program that either
give me poses a new option by licensing
using source files you can go on here
that use files even more ways artists
would love maximum number of Creative
Commons and Stobart why should this was
just saw okay so if you didn't figure it
out Justin Russell the student who made
that got ahold of the original flash
source right the flash file that's got
the tween to the timeline and frames and
the instances and all that stuff that
you need to really remix flash movie and
we sent it to creative comments they
laughed their heads off so that's just
an example of a yet one more sort of
hack of the system in this case it's
actually hack of one of the hacks right
because it's an alternative vision of
what a Creative Commons license could be
on that having been said I'll end with a
couple sort of notes about the future
because these things are all happening
now they're all contemporary but I think
we can go further there is a weakness of
open licenses there's but just to give
you one of them there's this kind of
porosity of fair use of something you
could license for example it's a can be
a matter of proportion one of the one of
the four prongs of the fair use test is
did you use a lot of the other person's
work or did you use just a little bit of
it if you used a very little bit of it
chances are you may be allowed a fair
use exemption from copyright
infringement and many of the samples
many of the songs on this wired CD are
released under these sampling license
that allows you to do that problem is
that sampling versus texture is a matter
of it's sort of this porosity there's a
permeability there in digital media
given how easy it is to modify something
right so you probably know the example
of from Jeffrey Herlings lecture of the
string of puppies by Jeff Koons and how
he he was sued for modifying a
photograph of a string of sappy looking
puppies and turning it into a
three-dimensional model well someone
could actually take one of those puppies
and have manipulated the background put
a flowery background and change the you
know text on it or something and create
a fair-use transformation of it there
wouldn't be anything like the original
right because it only used one puppy and
that might have stood up in court so
someone could apply a Creative Commons
license to that and then put it up on
the web the trouble is some other person
could take that not necessarily know the
derivation stream and then say well you
know I like that puppy but wouldn't it
be great with more puppies it's sort of
like Photoshop a whole bunch more of
them in you know clone them and so forth
and then recreate something that was
close back to the original one and then
maybe get slapped with a copyright suit
same could happen with like a riff from
you know Philip Glass no no no no no no
no no okay well i'm just going to sample
this don't know someone else's he
wouldn't be neat if I back right back
duh no no no no no no that you're back
to filled glass again so that's kind of
an issue with with a proportion and how
permeable the fair use domain is in
digital media there's also the
difference in purpose a purpose can't go
backwards and forwards we saw in Sivas
lecture no i think was Geoffrey's again
that parody is often protected whereas
satire often is not joy Garnett had a
sort of one of the versions of her piece
was a Pepsi Cola wielding sandanista you
know sort of Molotov cocktail with a
Pepsi slogan on it and we can imagine
that being a sort of parody of Pepsi
that might be qualified but if someone
turns it into an iPod advertisement by
putting an ipod and taking only the
silhouette you know well maybe that
isn't any longer a fair use of the piece
so I think there are some limits to this
open license approach and ultimately I'm
interested in exploring a more dramatic
hack of the copyright system in which an
entire domain or perhaps the entire
internet is not a Commons but a
sanctuary not a space where some things
are free and a lot of stuff is
controlled but it's basing where a lot
of things have a default freedom
attached to them and something like a
default share-alike non-commercial
license for streamable culture something
I proposed in the past we could talk
about it more but in general I think if
you look out at the out at the landscape
of digital culture and and remix abul
media that battle between the jurassic
giants and the fleet-footed you know
sort of velociraptors is still going on
the question is which side of that you
know kind of evolutionary divide do you
find yourselves on and how can we
basically change the rules not to
benefit the fleet-footed new
warm-blooded faster species but to at
least make it a level playing field
where they all compete on the same
ground and the evolution in its natural
course will determine which one of us is
best for society so thank you very much
and I'd be happy to take any questions
or demo any more things that I hinted at
during the talk
questions everybody got it down yeah I
mean maybe won't finish what you're
suggesting with people with white I'm
sorry with would withdraw from putting
things in your head that's right that's
a very good question um so the question
was within in this very sketchy vision
of this digital sanctuary that I
mentioned at the end would that maybe
persuade people not to put things online
because they would be nervous that it
would be taken ripped off so forth my
attitude toward that is a rather
practical one which is basically a
compromise between the content
industries like you know Hollywood and
record industries versus the the lowly
sort of do-it-yourself creator let's
suppose they want to try a new business
model where they puts things online you
have to pay to get in then I would say
go for it but if it gets hacked it's
kind of like a what's the phrase at your
own risk investment okay so there are
always people who are interested in
finding out ways to profit from the
internet as we know from the last you
know four years most of those ways have
utterly failed but I think there could
be ways to do that I just seen it I see
there be an incentive in terms of
society both to share things and also to
experiment with the technology and see
what's possible what's not right now
increasingly with digital rights
management to the DC ma we have all
these rules that basically say don't
tinker we don't even want you to try
tinkering with this and authors and and
commentators have said well you know
this is in antithetical to the spirit of
you know our society in general in
American culture in particular we are a
race of tinkerers we are people who who
do this this is thomas edison this is
benjamin franklin this is where we come
from as a people so my feeling about
that is like okay let them tinker but
also let the
other side ticker let the hackers tinker
let the people would lock culture tinker
and if there's an arms race there they
will sort of work it out on their own
rather than have you know some legal
restriction or technological lock inside
a computer prevent people from doing
that so metaphor would be if you're
walking you know digital media products
are like rabbits they reproduce so
quickly that's the danger of them right
even p3s once it's on the internet can
go everywhere you can take your rabbit
for a walk in the sanctuary you can put
a leash around that rabbit but if the
rabbit wriggles out from out of the
leash and runs into the sanctuary it's
now protected as part of the sanctuary
so that's that's the approach i would
take toward that problem it's another
question yes
as a time and way back to like when net
artists and then I wanted to be put in
this art institution siren at Lee was
the early project that I did yeah
there's a lot of other people in the
audience who could also respond to that
the short version i would say is that
there was a huge burst of interest
roughly coincident with the dot-com boom
that busted along with a dot-com bust
but what's happened is that the the
interest in preserving this kind of
culture has has percolated through the
establishment to the extent that there's
a lot more than net art that's going to
die if we don't take dramatic new
paradigms of preservation so the same
people who might never have fired up a
web browser who are curators and
archivists and registrar's and
conservators are looking at their video
installation or their spiral of sticks
or their corner of fat and saying whoa
you know the traditional storage
mechanisms aren't going to work for
these and since intended artists are
particularly clever and forward-thinking
bunch sometimes they can all learn from
each other and in this ironic sort of
underhanded way i would say internet
artists retains its relevance to the
museum because the solutions if you can
solve that that's the acid test right if
you can preserve internet art so the
benefit would have crew back to the
other works yeah
yeah I leave that up there let's see
yeah I was wondering the light of that
video we saw words that you know lawyers
eat one language and then there's humans
but that's sort of lawyers do speak and
the law speaks in very imp way so in
what ways do you think artists and
techniques can begin to speak to lawyers
and to the law in a way that they will
understand since I'm feeling if you got
you know if there were so many more
artists that could be true my beef was
not simply that there were lawyers
interested in finding a new system at
the assembly but they were lawyers
interested in containing you know
keeping the system the same because it
benefited their clients I you know the
riaa and mpaa but at answer your
question there are lawyers who are
really interested in changing the system
because almost everybody agrees that
it's broken it's just a matter of
whether your heart is in really seeing
the change or whether you're just
looking forward to the next paycheck
that's my view on those lawyers work for
the Electronic Frontier Foundation they
work for Creative Commons there's law
clinics around the country that are
really interested in these issues and it
beholds the artist to go to them and say
hey you know how can we help what can we
do to help sort of like you envision
these things because the source license
I mean that's why we built this you know
sort of demo they don't know that you
know it'll work with flash they're like
working on you know drafting contracts
and Microsoft Word or whatever that
that's not a native sort of medium for
them so for us to sort of educate them
about the value of having source media I
think is part of our mission and there's
lots of opportunities we're actually
trying in the open art network to
stimulate more of these anyone who's
interested for example if you're a video
artist who likes working with
high-definition formats in 2005 July you
won't be able to do it anymore at least
not through Tebow because macrovision
broadcast flag is being incorporated
into any kind of recording device what
does that mean it means you won't be
able to make artwork in which you sample
digital television high definition you
know digital satellite so fourths so
what the eff is doing is actually
creating one of these devices to do that
basically so that will be grandfathered
before the legislation and they're
looking for artists to use it to show
what interesting things you could do if
you had access to the ability to record
for fair uses and in many cases you know
the Supreme Court justices don't know
anything about art so people like lawyer
Lawrence Lessig talks about how he tried
to persuade them about the value of
letting things fall into the public
domain in the case about Eldred the
problem was he was someone forget who
one of the you know judges kept hitting
him with well show me the empirical
evidence show me show me what would be
possible with this you've told me that
it's possible is it suitor okay Scalia
yeah I think it was more not likely
Scalia but one of them and and and and
after the fact you know lesyk said to
himself you know he's right I should
have had some proof of concept and
artists can't provide that yeah
turns out not to be in fact they're
copyright once those are easily got
around but their marketing dollars and
you don't have the efflorescence most
people are still spending money I think
that's a very good critique and in its
one it suggests another problem with the
idea of of Creative Commons style
licenses as being the only solution I
think they're only part of the solution
but I do think there are some
interesting alternatives viral marketing
is an interesting idea something like
snapple you know if you look that's the
classic case of looking at something
that didn't use you know big industry
dollars to market itself and when it was
finally bought by whatever it was Quaker
Oats they completely bombed and
destroyed the brand by trying to market
it in the usual way but there's also
more creative sort of miss uses of
brands for example clay shirky who
studies social networks has described
has complained about peer-to-peer
systems in that they depend on a
taxonomy of celebrity that's already
there you don't go searching for a band
you don't know yet right most of us
don't search for Blue's research for you
know Led Zeppelin or whatever so it's
something you already know so it had to
have already been marketed by the record
labels for you to even search for it he
this that sort of critique was sort of
turned on its head by a student car lot
of inert singh who is another guy up in
Maine who suggested that people who want
to create their own brands should label
their their mp3's Madonna or Michael
Jackson or something like that and maybe
with a slight difference in spelling you
know like leaving out a vowel or using
alphanumerics or something like that so
that people who searched would find
those and gradually get to know them as
someone different from the real Madonna
so it'd be sort of like there would be
this this sort of shadow universe of
emerging musicians that that hijacked
the marketing of the celebrities I
thought that was an interesting approach
yeah
comment so my comment is well if it's
legal then it tastes like ass the
example blessing uses an independent
filmmaker making a document box won't
lamb license Simpsons for like
individual creators isn't it I've taken
stuff that remix and I never really
worry about it because I don't have
anything they sue me that I'm getting
there ever do I'm not I don't really
take part in file network so it like
they is there so a lot of the move
visual artists want to mix this stuff in
independent producers don't have capital
don't really have they can worry about
you know so we're going to protected by
our poverty and our unsuccess of coal
industry leader or something like that
so is it the creative common stuff sort
of work for you know protect capital
against capital you know connect
predator against predator that's very
interesting question I mean would you
say joy Garnett is a predator you know
she was the first presentation in this
lecture series and she created work I
know you guys remixed it in which it
borrowed a photograph stole a photograph
from a photojournalist she actually
didn't know who the photojournalist was
at the time and was later sued by that
person you know I don't think joy
Garnett is a brand name of the level of
someone that should be sued but she was
at the least served papers by that
original photographers attorney there's
also cases you mentioned Lessig's
description of the the the simpsons
excerpt read his story of the student at
was at rensselaer think okay we're on
you know basically this guy and I know
students at rensselaer who told me about
that they had this system that would
crash it was a university network based
on a Microsoft product I believe
in which you could search for files that
were on this network and it wasn't a
peer-to-peer you know music file sharing
system it was simply a university
network that was designed to help you
find resources right you know who's got
a copy of this where can I get that
there was a bug in it though if a file
if a computer was offline and you tried
to use it your whole computer would
crash this student did nothing but fix
the bug now it turns out the program was
also used to file to share a lot of
music and and copyrighted you know
programs illegally and this student was
sued to within well not within an inch
of his life to all of his life savings
you know it's one of these things where
it's like 150 thousand-dollar suit was
patently ridiculous but even the cost of
going to court the first time would have
been more that this student could afford
he had saved i believe twelve thousand
dollars for college and he was like a
sophomore and he's a first-year okay and
he gave it all you know they basically
said we'll settle for your entire life
savings thank you very much and take the
off the system right I think that's
someone pretty low on the totem pole
there you know that's like this that's
like the the you know bear asaurus
stomping on the little mammal french
right so i don't have a lot of faith in
your i like to believe your ID and I
think poverty is often a good shield but
in some cases you know I clearly it
hasn't been yeah right there up to 6,000
college students now and I presume those
aren't the Predators yeah one thing
that's interesting though but just to
key into this notion of predator as it
kind of metaphor the RIAA doesn't sue
people who download only it's whose
people who enable other people to get so
ironically the people who use the
because most most you know network
peer-to-peer software you you you can
check off I don't want to share I just
want to receive but a lot of people do
share because that's the waste basis of
the program on ironically those people
who do the unethical thing from the
network point of view are untouched by
the RIAA it's only the people who allow
others to upload in the case of Justin
whatever his name that the student would
even just did
technical correction to the system and
you know that's that's an interesting
thing because in some ways they view as
predators what from the perspective of
the network of shares are the most
altruistic people is there like
complementary alternative model of
distribution or I mean if all of the
creative media that was available online
is free I mean would that relegate our
that's a good question I've talked about
this in other contexts and I basically
think day jobs are underrated but
especially if you think about things
like the reputation network that I
showed put it back on the screen you
know here's some person who did a lot of
stuff for free right Matt James is one
of the most common contributors to the
pool this is his connections that he's
made with other people by using his
technical conceptual perceptual skills
in common projects and he's made this
network without having any financial you
know recompense at all but isn't that
network a valuable thing in and of
itself and isn't it a value in getting
him a day job you know in other words if
if there are at and there certainly are
in most even gift and reputation that
works times when money is made knowing
who the person is you know finding
collaborators finding the people
establishing the reputation is something
that usually takes years in an era of
you know networks and social networking
software it could take a matter of days
so that's one way in which i think the
the ethics of altruism and in examples
of the open networks I've described can
lead to you know sort of life you know
paying the bills funding funding the
computer the next laptop you're going to
buy and even if it didn't let's suppose
that this you know sort of someone makes
me king and the the internet is suddenly
a digital sanctuary for ninety-nine
percent of artists nothing's going to
change right it really isn't a big
change of the way people use the system
people tend to steer clear of gated
communities and subscriptions people
tend to gravitate to free content people
tend to share remix you know web
designers are constantly pilfering
JavaScript and code from each other and
they don't credit each other whatever so
for almost everybody it wouldn't change
for a tiny group of artists at the at
the sort of top market of the market
chain yes they might lose some
livelihood but I don't think most of
those artists are making money off the
internet right now
and often it's not from the sale of the
CD it's from all the other stuff live
concerts so for ya there's nothing to
say that these people wouldn't still
make money off the things that can't be
streamed and you know massage through a
modem you know live concerts for movies
immersive projections and big company
big you know movie theaters there's lots
of things you know bound leather books
you can bring to the beach all of this
stuff cannot be squeezed through a modem
and could still be you know paid for
using conventional models and could be
supercharged at least in terms of its
marketing by the representation of free
stuff online yeah sure I argue that
rather than using this sort of Turnitin
approach which is a lot like publisher
you drop a professor drops of paper that
they got from a student onto this icon
in their desktop it zooms up to some
database run by Turnitin they compare it
to all the other papers that they've
ever gotten they say oh this is the same
paper that the Sigma Phi Fraternity gave
us in 1996 you know and the professor
goes woo plagiarism plagiarism well many
things to about that are troubling to me
not the least of which is Turnitin has
created this large repository of
information of shared study and thought
that have been produced by students all
over the world and they are completely
owning the copyright and not sharing it
with anyone that seems like to me
completely unethical thing to do not to
mention the fact that if all these term
paper you know by my paper com kind of
places everyone out of business turn it
in would be out of a job so that makes
it a little suspicious to me I think
that Professor should be assigning
assignments that assume that we have the
internet we have access to more facts
than we could possibly deal with we have
access to argumentation that's taken
place in the past what we need is the
ability to take contextual decisions
about what's happening here and now and
if assignments are tailor made so that
you know it couldn't have been written
by anyone else because you tailored it
to that class or that student then you
solve that problem in terms of other
kinds of assignments my favorite one was
I had a video that was kind of boring
that I wanted to have students watch and
I realized you know people in the real
world they don't read every every word
of a book they don't see half of the
movies or or concerts that they talk
about they get it from word of mouth
okay someone has to see it somewhere but
the discourse can be beyond that it
doesn't have to be absorbing every minut
moment of a particular cultural
phenomenon so I said all right look I
know some of you in this class it was
maybe a class of 20 or so I know some of
you in class have seen this movie before
all right I want you to share that
information with everybody else in the
class you're going to do it in groups
I'm gonna walk in I'm going to interview
each group one at a time if I can tell
who in your group didn't watch that
movie that entire group gets a see if I
can't tell who in your group watch the
movie but are you know who didn't that
is all of you make me convinced me that
you did watch it then you all get a B if
I can't tell this for all of the groups
that is the entire class I can't pick
one person and say you didn't watch the
movie I'm sure of it you all get an A
they got to be one one person it was
down a last person and he was like oh
yeah no definitely I watched it but you
know obviously someone hadn't done their
homework so obviously the incentive
there is to collaborate rather than to
poured information and a bunch of people
collaborate on our work
a couple of slackers who aren't pulling
their weight happy hit tell if you know
everybody can you give the project in a
how can you tell it everybody deserves
that it it's not so much proven II saw a
video but but working together working
together on artwork if you do it in the
pool you have a real nice trace of who
did what because it's all kind of track
but even if you do it in in another
context where you're making a mural or
you know big sculpture or whatever
sometimes you could person must have
been a slacker and she realized she had
to go make some more work but you know
if it is some other context one of this
one of the techniques you can use is to
have everyone in the group evaluate each
other privately obviously anonymously
and then give you those evaluations and
you can usually I never I don't usually
say well I'll just take whatever you
give me I sell take it under advisement
maybe I'll factor they're great in with
mine whatever but that you know I find
especially when you when you allow the
person to evaluate themselves a lot of
times people are really honest and
they're like well you know Joe really
pulled his weight and mary did a lot
more than me and I I don't know in my
experience that that system has worked
it also wrap it up right now thank you